hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear going back to the 1990s
for this one now i've been a big fan of
guillermo del toro since
the first film of his that i saw which
was either the devil's backbone which
came out in 2001 or pan's labyrinth from
2006. i can't remember like which one of
those i saw first
but there's just always been something
about
his particular vision in filmmaking i
guess he's very into
the idea of the beautiful grotesque and
he just has this sense of wonder and
magic and stuff you can tell he's really
really into horror like he really loves
it and that really comes across in all
of his stories like even when some of
them are really sad or really tragic and
he also has that thing where he also um
embraces the monster embraces the
outsider and i kind of feel like a lot
of the stuff that he does in his films
like really resonates with me
particularly and so i've enjoyed pretty
much every single one of his movies that
i've seen and i've seen pretty much well
almost all of them um i even like his
sort of bigger budget ones um even
though i obviously prefer his more
personal films now shortly after i saw
the two movies that i just mentioned uh
pan's labyrinth and the devil's backbone
i actually discovered uh guillermo del
toro's first feature film chronos which
came out in 1993
and was made when he was only 29 years
old and it's like i've seen like behind
the scenes photos of it and he for real
like just looks like a kid it's like
really really funny
now at the time that i first heard of it
which was probably i don't know 2007
2008 somewhere around there i kind of
feel like a lot of people weren't really
talking about it and um i actually
wasn't i mean
video rental places were still a thing
then and i went to rent it and they
didn't have it like you know because i
grew up somewhere where they didn't have
like a lot of weird movies that you
could rent but i actually was able to
buy a version of it online it was like a
dvd and it was like the 10th anniversary
one so it came out in 2003 so i was able
to get that so i actually do own a copy
now this is actually cronus is actually
like a fascinating movie to watch
because
it demonstrates pretty clearly that
even at that young of an age like a
relatively young age for a filmmaker all
of the attributes that make del toro
like one of the most beloved and
esteemed filmmakers in the world like
still to this day were already really
firmly in place like he really had a
sense of his own identity and what he
wanted to put across in film so kronos
is essentially a vampire story but
because it's guillermo del toro that
we're talking about he actually puts a
really unique spin on this kind of like
classic and maybe a little bit stale
monster and to the story he sort of adds
like a lot of his traditional uh kind of
themes to it there's like this kind of
melancholy that a lot of his movies have
like they're very gothic they're very
elegant and they also usually have like
a really um like a lot of heart to them
like a really good like emotional core
and they also have like a lot of dark
humor to them they tend to and this one
has all of those things uh you know in
spades
uh so at the beginning of the movie
there's a little bit of a prologue
and we learned that there was like an
alchemist named fulcanelli who was
actually i didn't know this but it was
based on a real guy like a french
alchemist like you know if you don't
want to check out falconelli like uh go
to the wikipedia page like about him and
he's like really interesting
so this alchemist was living in mexico
in the 16th century it was like 1563 or
something or 1530 something now he
invents something called a kronos device
what this is is a little
gold
clockwork style mechanism thing it looks
kind of like a scarab and it can
actually bestow everlasting life
through a method which you don't
actually learn what it is until later on
so the prologue then goes on to show
that this alchemist actually lived until
1937
when it so happened that there was like
an earthquake in mexico and it toppled
the building that he was living in and
it sort of caused this stray wooden beam
to kind of fall on him and like pierce
through his heart which killed him now
his body was found in the wreckage by
authorities but the fact that the
building also housed a bunch of big
basins that were full of presumably
human blood uh that was actually never
disclosed to the public so there was
this kind of like creepy like urban
legend kind of vibe about it so we then
jump ahead to december of 1996 i think
it's like right after christmas
interestingly and i'm not really sure
what the deal with this is but the movie
is actually set three years after it was
actually made because it was made in
1993 but it's set at the end of 1996.
and i'm not exactly sure why i didn't
know if he wanted to make it so that
like it was a 400 year gap like between
when when the alchemist died or
something like that or when the
alchemist like made the thing i don't
really know and why 400 years i don't
really know but anyway it's it's set
like in the future which i thought was
kind of strange
so there's an old man named jesus greece
or greece greece whatever
uh who's actually played by the
argentinian actor federico lupi who was
in a [ __ ] ton of stuff but he was also
in pan's labyrinth as well now he runs
an antique shop in mexico city
and he has uh this granddaughter named
aurora who uh he's really really i mean
he just adores her and dotes on her all
the time now aurora actually lives with
jesus and his wife mercedes after her
parents were killed i don't even know if
they mentioned in the movie like how the
parents were killed because it happened
like prior to the events of the film so
she's been living with them
now in a recent shipment to his antique
shop jesus has got this like archangel
statue
but he hasn't really completely
unwrapped it yet so because he's got a
bunch of packages in there and they're
all just like still in the wrappers
so after he opens the shop one morning
this very sketchy young man like wanders
into the shop and seems like really
really interested in that in particular
and he starts pulling aside the paper
like from the face um and he's i don't
know he's just acting really weird like
he's gonna like rob the place so because
he's so particularly interested in this
one item after you know shifty mcrobber
pants like leaves the store
jesus decides he's gonna check out this
statue or whatever it is like more
closely
so one of the angels eyes is broken and
so he puts it on the desk and in a scene
that absolutely made my [ __ ] skin
crawl a bunch of cockroaches come
scuttling out of the hole which yeah i'm
like really really grossed out by
cockroaches so that always kind of made
me go wow like because all these roaches
coming out but yeah so they all come out
which demonstrates to jesus that the
statue is hollow and he kind of like
knocks around on it and he hears that
there's maybe something concealed in
there so he pries up the base um and
jesus and aurora actually discover the
kronos device like underneath the base
of this um but of course they don't know
what it is they're just kind of like oh
what's this neat little thing it's like
a little gold thing about i don't know
about the size of a donut or something
like that maybe not that big it's
actually like i said it's kind of a
scarab size so like i said jesus is kind
of amused and he starts like tinkering
around with it
and the little mechanism comes on
on the top and starts like spinning
around and then like little legs with
spikes on the ends kind of shoot out the
sides of this thing and it clamps like
down on the palm of his hand and starts
drawing a substantial amount of blood
like it really does uh cause quite quite
an injury now of course he can't see
this like he can't see what's going on
inside but there is like a really cool
shot of the inside of the device that
shows us the audience that there's
actually a living insect inside and it's
kind of like intertwined with all the
clockwork and it appears to be drinking
the blood now obviously this insect has
been alive for 400 years 460 years
whatever it is at this point so like i
said it was an alchemist that made it so
it's like magical realism now
subsequently after this happens like he
gets this injury from the thing
he starts to feel jesus starts to feel a
little weird like not bad necessarily uh
actually quite good he starts to look
and feel younger like his hair gets
thicker and like some of his wrinkles go
away and he feels like a lot more
vigorous and all this other kind of so
he feels like he's like getting a lot
younger
but he's also um developed a hankering
for something that he can't quite put
his finger on what it is like he's just
seems like he's thirsty all the time and
he's like drinking all this water and
it's like not helping and he's like
awake at night he seems really anxious
and all this other kind of stuff
so at last he figures out
that it's actually the device that he
wants
and
much like an addict he starts sneaking
around in the middle of the night and
like clamping it onto himself like onto
his chest and stuff like that and kind
of letting it do its thing which i'm
presuming is either drinking his blood
or like putting
something else in his blood or maybe
it's an exchange or something like that
he also begins to develop an insatiable
desire to drink blood uh even in one
kind of uh well-known scene licking some
off a bathroom floor at a new year's eve
party after there's been a guy in there
who had a nosebleed so his granddaughter
aurora who were led to that i don't
think she's necessarily mute because she
can talk but she only actually says one
word uh in the entire film so i don't
know i think they were trying to imply
that maybe she was on the spectrum or
something like that um i think the only
word she says is grandfather toward the
end uh although i guess it'd be abuelo
or whatever because it's this is mostly
in spanish there is some english but um
it's mostly in spanish uh so yeah so she
only says one word in the whole movie so
aurora though is like actually worried
about what's happening to him and as it
turns out the kronos device transforming
her beloved grandfather into a vampire
essentially uh isn't really the only
concern that she should probably have
because you see there is also in town
this wealthy businessman whose name is
dieter d laguardia now he's actually
played by claudio brooke uh who was in a
[ __ ] ton of movies but i had seen him in
he was in the devil's reign from 1975
with you know william shatner and he was
also in the 1989 james bond movie
license to kill so he was in that as
well so he plays uh this businessman and
he's dying from some wastings i'm
presuming it's cancer or something like
that and um he is actually in possession
of a book that was written by the
alchemist vulcanelli and it has all the
stuff about the kronos device in it like
how we made it and how it works and all
this other kind of stuff so he's
actually spent the last few years
scouring the globe essentially to find
the kronos device so that he can live
forever
and he knows that it's in the statue
like he knows what the statue that it
was hidden in like looks like but he
doesn't know where exactly it is because
there are a lot of statues that look
like that you know what i mean so you
can see like in his office there's all
the statues that he had bought um that
didn't have them in there and he just
kind of has him hanging up in like
plastic like in his uh office or
whatever
so uh his bruiser of a nephew
uh angel who's actually played by ron
perlman in this and the hilarious thing
i saw this on the imdb trivia page but
they said that initially they wanted to
get ron perlman to speak spanish in the
film but after he read his lines in
spanish uh guillermo del toro was like
yeah don't do that um we're gonna
we're gonna make he does like say a few
things in spanish but he says it like
purposefully bad because they changed
his character to be like an american
who's living in mexico and he doesn't
really like it there so he's just like
being a jerk by like speaking spanish
badly because he actually did speak
spanish badly so they kind of wrote that
into his character but i just thought
that was really funny so yeah so he's
kind of like angel
is basically like his uncle's enforcer
like he hates his uncle and he wishes
his uncle would hurry up and drop dead
because he's supposed to get this big
inheritance and the only way that he
will keep in the uncle's good graces is
by going around and like trying to get
this kronos device but ironically he's
also kind of in a pickle because if he
does actually find the chronos device
and give it to his uncle like his uncle
wants then he will never get the
inheritance because his uncle will never
die so like i said he's kind of a little
bit of a rage monster in this uh you
know understood he's definitely a bad
guy but that's kind of why because he's
like in a no-win situation so he
actually comes to the antique shop at
first and buys the statue for some like
princely sum of money and not knowing
that um that jesus has already taken the
chronos device out of it so when he gets
back to the uncle's office and like they
go in there and they figure out that the
kronos device isn't there and they're
pretty sure that that's where it was so
then he starts like targeting jesus and
the shop like he trashes the shop and
he's basically like you have to come
here and um you know give us the device
because we have the book you don't know
how it works you don't know what it is
and all this other kind of stuff so he
basically like targets uh jesus so
there's that whole thing going on too so
these these two bad guys are also trying
to get the kronos device off of jesus
even though at this point like um jesus
has become essentially like addicted to
the thing now eventually um angel
actually ends up killing jesus at least
he thinks he does by pushing his car off
a cliff but because jesus's heart wasn't
pierced because that's the only way he
can kill them he actually gets he
actually revives like while he's in the
undertaker's like they're just about to
um they do like the thing and then
they're just about ready to cremate him
and he actually like wakes up and leaves
and this is actually one of the funniest
scenes in the movie like it's very black
humor but i really like that so this is
like one of the funniest things with
like the two uh the two guys like the
funeral director and the assistant i
think now interestingly these two guys
and this is another little random bit of
trivia the funeral director and his
assistant from this movie actually the
actors like reprise the same characters
in a movie like a mexican movie called
we are what we are it's not the there i
know there was like an american or a
canadian one or something like that that
came out in 2013 that was called that i
think it was about cannibals but this is
a different movie this was like a
mexican uh or mexican or spanish at
least a spanish language film this came
out in 2010 and it's almost considered
like a standalone sequel to kronos even
though it's kind of like a different
story but those two characters uh repeat
in that one and i haven't seen that but
now i have to see it because i hadn't
heard of it before now so yeah so now
that jesus is
dead but now he's like undead obviously
um his body starts to deteriorate
but aurora his uh granddaughter loves
him just the same and she actually ends
up like trying to help him like defeat
dieter and angel and the film ends like
a little bit ambiguously because i'm not
entirely sure like jesus isn't really
sure either if destroying the device
will kill him or will return him to
normal and you don't really know like
which of those things is gonna happen so
i will say that even though kronos isn't
quite as i guess self-assured or
polished as guillermo del toro's later
films were which like i said not a big
surprise because i think it only cost
million and a half two million to make
which you know only two million dollars
but yeah for a movie that's not much and
it was his first movie and he was like
really young but it's so it's like
surprisingly assured for that you know
for being like his first film and
everything but it's still like a really
i mean it's an extraordinary debut
really i mean it's a dark fantasy i
guess it's it's a horror movie but i
would call it a little bit more like on
the dark fantasy end but it does have
quite a bit of gore it's has like a
really original take on the vampire
mythos as i said and it has like a
really strong emotional core at center
about you know the unconditional love
between like aurora like even though
like still loving her grandfather and
still helping him even though he's
turning into a monster and also has some
stuff to say about maybe like the
poisonous lure of immortality like what
you'll give up to get that
and i will say that even though jesus uh
you know the main character he falls
victim to the kronos device accidentally
like he doesn't know what it is he just
finds it in the bottom of thing he's
like oh neat and then like you know he
essentially just gets turned into a
vampire like by accident but he ends up
becoming like something of a slave to it
um but he's still like sympathetic uh
throughout the whole entire movie even
as he
you know toward the end like he starts
struggling with his desire to like drink
the blood of his granddaughter and he's
kind of like able to not do that like
because he still retains enough of his
humanity um so it's really like a lot of
del toro's films it's very beautiful and
it's very sad and it's kind of like a
tale about addiction about you know the
lengths people will go to
maybe to get like a little bit more time
than their due or to get like eternal
life or things like that and it also has
some stuff to say like i said about
unconditional love and how sometimes it
can overcome like even like the worst
evil
so i mean if you've enjoyed any of
guillermo del toro's other movies but
haven't got around to seeing this one um
i would definitely recommend it
because it's just a really outstanding
horror film and it kind of like examines
a lot of del toro's favorite themes and
a lot of his visual touchstones so it's
really kind of interesting to see
where it all started i guess so yeah if
you haven't seen it you definitely
should if you have hbo max it's on there
but i'm sure you can find it elsewhere i
watched it on hbo max but i'm sure you
know you can find it other places too
there's also a criterion collection uh
version of it like on blu-ray so you
know if you want to go that route but
yeah so that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys
again on the next one bye